ce système personne ne le contrôle des
ne va pas seulement changer les banques
centrales ça va changer le concept même
de l'état nation
le bitcoin c'est une monétisation de
l'amour et de la paix
[Musique]
avec nous antoine perrut de bonjour
bonjour vous êtes cio comme on disait
dans les grandes entreprises
multinationales de saint gobain russie
ukraine on a beaucoup dit que bon
l'ouest et caïcos l'eau mais que l'est
et paul bert moi je suis convaincu à
titre personnel que les faut réduire les
émissions de carbone sur la planète
entière donc les plus observés il faut
réduire les émissions de carbone dans
les pays en développement sur partout
partout vous avez construit des usines
décarbonés pour des usines où on est
mais rien du tout comme carbone dans
l'usiné que ce soit nos émissions
directes ou alors des émissions liées à
la production d'électricité nous en
avons aujourd'hui dans le monde donc la
conscience écologique aussi existence
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous nous sommes ensemble
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
jusqu'à 21h30 pour décrypter les grands
titres de l'actualité de la journée
au sommaire de ce mercredi 22 septembre
l'heure est à la mise au point entre
emmanuel macron et joe biden après la
crise des sous marins
le président français s'est entretenu
aujourd'hui avec son homologue américain
une clarification entre à propos du
contrat du siècle rompu par l'australien
au profit est des états unis laissant
paris sur le bas côté la france pouvait
elle ignorer la rupture de cet accord
avant l'annoncé officielle de canberra
quelle option désormais s'offre à elle
pour sortir la tête et au décryptage
dans quelques instants
dans notre rendez-vous qu'en pensent les
français ce soir nous sommes allés à la
rencontre d'un père de famille qui a
perdu son fils il ya 13 ans en
afghanistan alors qu'il était engagé
dans l'armée française pour lui il est
mort pour rien aujourd'hui elle est
aliments remettent la règle religion au
dessus de tout et finalise un
gouvernement sans femmes ils demandent
une tribune à l'assemblée générale des
nations unies au nom de l'afghanistan
au sommaire à 21h la situation sanitaire
en france fin du port du masque à
l'école primaire le 4 octobre prochain
dans les territoires les moins touchés
par l'épidémie mais le pass sanitaire
lui est maintenu par tous pour l'instant
dans tous les départements pour certains
syndicats du primaire et certains
médecins la levée partielle de cette
obligation semble précipité alors
faut-il s'inquiéter de cette direction
prise par le gouvernement réponse danger
leurs
[Musique]
le temps des grands explications
emmanuel macron et joe biden se sont
donc parlé au téléphone pour la première
fois depuis la crise des sous marins
avec l'australie on retrouve un atom
abonné depuis new york
bonsoir thomas
bonsoir thomas le ton semble plutôt à
l'apaisement entre paris et washington
oui avec une première décision
importante prise par emmanuel macron à
l'issue de cet entretien téléphonique
l'ambassadeur de france aux états unis
va retourner à washington dès la semaine
prochaine alors un communiqué conjoint a
été publié à l'issue de cet entretien
téléphonique entre joe biden et emmanuel
macron un entretien que la maison
blanche a qualifiée d'amicale auprès des
journalistes du new york times alors
dans ce communiqué pas d' excuses de la
part de washington mais les deux
présidents ont convenu je cite que des
consultations ouvertes entre alliés
auraient permis d'éviter la crise des
sous marins australiens joe biden a fait
part de son engagement durable à ce
sujet alors le communiqué annonce aussi
qu'une rencontre aura lieu entre les
deux présidents à la fin du mois
d'octobre en europe et d'ici là les deux
diplomaties vont désormais travailler à
renouer la confiance entre paris et
washington écoutez un extrait de ce
communiqué
les deux dirigeants ont décidé d'ouvrir
un processus de consultations
approfondies avec l'objectif de créer
les conditions pour assurer la confiance
et proposer des mesures concrètes menant
à des objectifs communs les etats unis
reconnaissent aussi l'importance d'une
défense européenne plus forte qui
contribuent positivement à la sécurité
transatlantique est globale et qui est
complémentaire de l'otan alors vous
l'aurez constaté c'est un communiqué
écrit dans un langage diplomatique qui a
surtout pour objectif de mettre fin à
cette crise profonde entre les deux pays
en jouant l'apaisement et en renouant le
dialogue entre les deux diplomaties on
notera tout de même l'approbation
américaine pour une défense européenne
sujet qui avait cristallisé les tensions
dans le passé on rappelle que cet
entretien un téléphone qui a été
réalisée à la demande de joe biden pour
clarifier la situation il ya des médias
américains ici qui a affirmé en citant
des sources au sein de la maison blanche
que le président américain avait été
surpris par l'ampleur de la réaction
française à noter aussi que ce mercredi
jean yves le drian et anthony blinken se
sont rencontrés en marge d'une réunion
de l'onu sur la libye les deux hommes
ont échangé une poignée de main et il
s'agissait à ce moment là du premier
contact entre les diplomaties française
et américaine depuis le début de cette
crise reste maintenant à savoir c'est
une réunion plus formel un tête à tête
entre les deux hommes va être organisée
ici à new york dans les prochaines
heures alors tout n'est pas réglé
évidemment dans cette crise diplomatique
qui risque de laisser des traces on
rappelle quand même que les mots ont été
très durs du côté français depuis près
d'une semaine et les prochains échanges
entre paris et washington risque d'être
riche d'enseignements comme l'ont été
finalement les réactions des différentes
chancelleries européennes sur leur
positionnement par rapport à cette crise
diplomatique que beaucoup estiment être
la crise diplomatique la plus grave
entre la france et les états unis depuis
le non à la guerre en irak c'était en
2003 merci tu auras bonnet en direct de
new york et dans le sillage de leurs
deux présidents les ministres des
affaires étrangères français et
américain dot donc échangé ce soir lors
d'une réunion à l'onu de son côté
l'australie soutient avoir exprimé sa
réticence à la france sur ce contrat des
sous marins mais une toute autre version
est défendue du côté de paris cyrielle
bruit
la france n'en démord pas mardi soir le
porte-parole du ministère des armées
hervé grange ans s'est exprimé au sujet
de la rupture unilatérale du contrat
portant sur les sous marins australiens
il dénonce la duplicité de l'exécutif
australien vis-à-vis de ses alliés mais
aussi de ses propres équipes il est
probable que ce nouveau projet est été
ourdi et préparer dans un tout tout
petit cercle on a un test le fait que
même des hauts gradés de la marine
australienne des éminents représentants
du ministère de la défense ont découvert
totalement le projet je peux même vous
dire certains d'entre eux ont pleuré
quand ils ont assisté aux déclarations
des trois chefs d'état et premiers
ministres
le soir du 15 septembre ce qui montre le
degré d'impréparation ou en tout cas de
défaut d'information du premier ministre
morrison vers ses équipes un doublé
australien déjà mis en cause quelques
heures plus tôt devant l'assemblée
nationale par la ministre des armées
florence parly les sous marins de la
classe attaque c'est à dire ceux dont
nous ce dont nous étions convenus entre
la france et l'australie sont les
meilleurs du monde dans le domaine des
sous-marins conventionnels
ce contrat n'a donc pas été décidé pour
des raisons qui tiennent à la qualité
des produits fournis par navale groupe
il a été décidé pour convenance comme
cela a été indiqué pour convenance et
cela n'a rien à voir avec notre
industrie et la qualité de nos produits
le deuxième ce sont les états unis qui
sont évidemment de plus en plus
focalisés sur l'inde au pacifique et sur
la chine et qui n'hésitent donc plus à
s'asseoir sur les intérêts et le
dialogue avec leurs plus vieil allié la
france la crise australienne nous
montrent que nous ne pouvons compter que
sur nous mêmes et que l'europe doit se
donner les moyens d'agir de son côté le
premier ministre australien scott
morrison réfute les accusations
française et justifie son choix en
déclarant avoir agi dans l'intérêt de
son pays la première responsabilité d'un
premier ministre d'un dirigeant de
n'importe quel pays et sa sécurité
nationale est de toujours faire passer
ses intérêts nationaux en premier en
assurant ce qu'il ya de mieux son propre
peuple
il serait naïf de penser qu'une décision
de cette nature ne va pas causer de la
déception évidemment aux français nous
le comprenons nous le reconnaissons
totalement et nous savions que ce serait
le cas et il n'était pas possible pour
nous de pouvoir discuter de questions si
sécuritaires concernant nos relations
avec d'autres pays à ce moment là
en déplacement à new york pour
l'assemblée générale de l'onu le premier
ministre australien a éludé depuis toute
question sur le sujet lors d'un
entretien mardi soir joe biden et scott
morrison se sont toutefois réjouis de
leur nouveau partenariat stratégique
est la ministre des armées qui s'est
aussi exprimée au sénat aujourd'hui
interpellé sur d'éventuels manquements
français florence parly assèchement
défendu l'action du gouvernement récolte
en critique et huées des parlementaires
puisque
[Musique]
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
claude blanchemaison expert en relations
internationales bon soif revanche maison
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous les
ministres un responsable français on les
a vus ce matin se succéder dans les
médias pour fustiger le double jeu le
mensonge australien sur le thème on
s'est fait berner manipuler on ne
pouvait pas savoir peut-on
raisonnablement y croire et surtout
est-ce que ça n'arrange pas aujourd'hui
et responsables français en face on a vu
au critique farouche de l'opposition de
passer plutôt pour des victimes que pour
des incompétents notamment en matière de
renseignement
sans doute mais on connaît maintenant
exactement là la chronologie des faits
ce contrat franco australien a été signé
à la fin de 2016 ou 2018 l'australie a
changé de premier ministre il ya
peut-être là aussi un problème de
politique intérieure et scott morrison
l'année suivante a décidé de la création
d'une petite commission secrète très
restreinte on en a parlé tout à l'heure
des amiraux en réalité il se trouve que
comme par hasard cette commission
indépendante avait un amiral américain à
la retraite qui participaient à ces
travaux c'était pour trouver une voie
alternative c'est à dire dans le fond
est ce qu'il n'ya pas une autre solution
morrison le nouveau premier ministre
australien voulais explorer 7 7 7 voix
et puis finalement effet boris johnson
ayant été saisi par les australiens
s'est dit qu'il y avait là un boulevard
pour trouver un élément de politique
étrangère post break site puisque
effectivement il faut que ce qu'il
démontre qu'il a une véritable politique
étrangère avec le monde entier et pour
cela il a entrepris au sommet du g7 de
cornouaille de convaincre joe biden
qu'il fallait qu'il lève ce qui était un
tabou chez aux états unis l'interdiction
de vendre des sous-marins à propulsion
nucléaire parce que ces produits et ces
proliférant et que d'ailleurs aucun des
pays nucléaires aucun des cinq membres
permanents du conseil de sécurité ne
vend des sous marins à propulsion
nucléaire pas plus les états unis que la
france ou d'autres simplement la russie
pendant dix ans à louer pas donné pas à
donner un sous marin à propulsion
nucléaire alain mais c'est aujourd'hui
terminé donc ça c'est ce qui s'est passé
et effectivement après le g7
après le g7 est bien là le complot a
s'est déroulé est effectivement assez
mise en place jusqu'à la déclaration
publique du 15 septembre est ce que il y
avait eu vent de cette affaire on dit
que l'entreprise laval groupe en effet
avait eu quelques problèmes avec ses
partenaires au niveau technique et
l'ingénieur australien mais c'est
compliqué parce que l'australie n'a
personne qui est une compétence
nucléaire ni sur le civil ni sur autre
chose et par conséquent il fallait
former les gens peut-être quelques fois
par être un petit peu paternaliste aussi
donc ait eu des frottements à ce niveau
là est ce que c est qu sont remontés là
je n'ai pas d'information particulière
mais il est possible qu'une aval groupe
n'avait pas envie de d'en faire tout un
tout un plat auprès de sa tutelle
c'est-à-dire du ministère de la défense
et que ceux ci a été à bas bruit tout
toute façon est en effet les services
compétents apparemment n'ont pas fait de
véritables rapports sur le sujet alors
l'actualité de la journée et de la
soirée même c'est emmanuel macron et joe
biden qui se sont enfin entretenu comme
nous le disait thomas bonne et tout à
l'heure le ton semble du toit à
l'apaisement retour de l'ambassadeur
annonce de consultations approfondies
l'admettent quand même tous les deux que
des consultations ouvertes aurait permis
d'éviter la crise entre la france et les
etats unis c'est le moins qu'on puisse
dire ça veut dire quoi concrètement les
états unis dans cette affaire s'en
sortent plutôt bien le perdant capitule
bons joueurs je pense qu'il ya trois
éléments essentiels dans la discute dans
la le communiqué conjoint qui a suivi sa
conversation téléphonique est en effet
le fait que quand même joe biden
reconnaît que s'il y avait eu
consultation que bien on n'en serait pas
là aujourd'hui donc c'est un petit peu
une contrition
américaine en effet à bon compte par
ailleurs il dit qu'à l'avenir il y aura
des consultations sur tous les sujets
montrait bien on va voir et il reconnaît
que la défense européennes doit être
renforcé
bien sûr dans le cadre de l'otan il
reconnaît l'importance de ce que nous
faisons au sahel il reconnaît aussi
l'importance de la contribution
française et européenne à la stratégie
indo pacifique et c'est là que il va y
avoir en effet des consultations et
peut-être des actions françaises et
européennes c'est justement l'option
effectivement de sortir peut-être la
tête haute la seule option de la france
aujourd'hui c'est la seule option
indienne on le saura à la fin de la
semaine puisque le premier ministre
indien vient d'atterrir aux états unis
il reste quatre jours l'invitation de
joe biden qu'il va rencontrer il va
faire un discours à l'onu et il va aussi
avoir une réunion à 4 le fameux quad
d'ailleurs les etats-unis l'inde le
japon et l'australie et probablement que
joe biden va lui faire des propositions
dans la ligne de ce qu'il a déjà fait
sans aller aussi loin avec l'australie
l'un d'eux n'aime pas beaucoup l'idée
d'alliance militaire l'inde sans doute
très bien avoir aussi des sous marins à
propulsion nucléaire mais elle ne paiera
pas le prix fort qui divise les états
unis c'est à dire l'alliance militaire
parce qu'elle veut rester à équidistance
entre la chine les états des états unis
et la russie et les pays européens
par conséquent peut-être y at-il là une
opportunité pour la france pour fournir
davantage de matériel et d'équipements
militaires dans le cadre d'ailleurs de
la coopération stratégique qui existe
depuis un peu plus de vingt ans avec ce
pays vous l'avez évoqué thomas bonnet
aussi un joe biden qui juge nécessaire
une défense européenne plus forte en
complément de l'otan samedi quoique
logement dans la maison cette
déclaration parce qu'on sait que ce
sujet avait cristallisé quelques
tensions et quelques années notamment
entre donald trump et emmanuel macron ce
c'est une étape aujourd'hui oui c'est
une étape en tout cas au niveau où
déclaratoire mais les états unis peuvent
faire cet effort
pour en effet nous faire plaisir puisque
c'était un vieux thèmes français très
anciens ils savent très bien qu à
l'intérieur de l'union européenne il ya
une division très importante keynes et
faisant il ne s'effacera pas avec ce
genre de déclaration à savoir que les
polonais et les baltes considère que
seuls les états unis garantissant leur
sécurité et qu'aucune autre couac aucun
autre arrangement européen ne peut
garantir leur sécurité alors
effectivement maintenant ça va être à la
diplomatie française de jouer au niveau
européen pour voir comment réunir un
noyau le plus large possible qui
acceptent une coopération européenne
vers des éléments de défense européenne
mais ça sera très long et très difficile
il ya déjà des éléments en l'afrique
puisque certains pays de l'union
européenne participe à la formation de
troupes de l'armée malienne participent
aussi des opérations au niger et au
burkina faso mais évidemment c'est à la
carte c'est à dire que ce sont
simplement les états membres qui sont
volontaires pour le faire pourquoi pas
des coopérations à la carte dans le
domaine militaire et dans le domaine de
la défense le point clé évidemment pour
les américains comme pour nous c'est
qu'il fournit l'armement il ne peut pas
y avoir en effet à fournisseur exclusif
la concurrence doit jouer et un certain
nombre de pays fabrique des équipements
militaires et par conséquent doivent
pouvoir doit pouvoir les fournir avec à
terre interopérabilité comme on dit
naturellement entre les différents
participants merci beaucoup à claude
blanchemaison nous avoir apporté votre
analyse ce soir et alors
alors que l'assemblée générale de l'onu
se tient à new york en ce moment les
talibans demandent eux à pouvoir
s'exprimer
face l'ambassadeur du gouvernement déchu
chassé du pouvoir le 15 août dernier qui
veut également prendre la parole à la
tribune peu de réaction 1 pour l'instant
cette demande des talibans on retiendra
ce soir là répond sans détour du
ministre allemand des affaires
étrangères il comme à s'écouter
je ne pense pas que les dépôts de
spectacles aux nations unies soient
utiles ce qui est important c'est que
les exigences que nous avons communiqué
aux talibans en matière de respect des
droits de l'homme notamment les droits
des femmes et un gouvernement inclusif
mais aussi le fait qu'ils doivent
clairement se distancer des groupes
terroristes soient enfin étayés par des
faits concrets en plus des belles
paroles
et en attendant sur place en afghanistan
la question du respect des droits
civiques et notamment celui des femmes
interroge toujours est taliban finaliser
ces derniers jours leur gouvernement et
non nommé aucune femme contrairement à
leurs promesses et détails avec yamina
benguigui da un rideau pour séparer les
femmes des hommes comme un gage de bonne
volonté des talibans vers les exigences
de la communauté internationale
dans cette université de caen d'art les
étudiantes ne sont pas mécontentes
la séparation de nos classes des garçons
a des avantages le premier avantage est
que lorsqu'il y avait des garçons dans
les classes nous ne pouvions pas posé
beaucoup de questions mais maintenant
nous pouvons librement poser des
questions et répondre aux questions de
l'enseignant et ainsi de suite et le
deuxième avantage est que je me sentais
mal à l'aise dans la classe il parlait
beaucoup et nous avions des difficultés
mais maintenant tout est devenu plus
facile pour moi
[Musique]
donner la possibilité aux femmes
d'accéder aux universités ne met
toutefois pas fin aux inquiétudes de
certaines femmes privés de leur emploi
et encore moins au lendemain de
l'annoncé définitive du gouvernement au
complet qui n'intègre aucune femme
c'est ancien employé d'une ong
internationale n'en démordent pas
pas question pour l'instant je reste
dans mon pays je veux me battre et
retrouver les droits qu'ils nous ont
pris j'espère que cela portera ses
fruits et que les talibans respecteront
leurs paroles il n'y a pas de raison que
nous devions fuir dans un autre pays
c'est notre patrie notre maison sur leur
échoit la mort à tarnos montrant nez
creux deux mois soit valeur marteau cole
oui je travaillais lorsque les talibans
sont arrivés ils ont mis en place
certaines restrictions ce qui a eu pour
effet que les femmes ne pouvaient pas
aller au bureau pour travailler et donc
j'ai perdu mon emploi je travaillais
pour une ong internationale
ne pas se mettre la communauté
internationale à dos c'est la stratégie
que souhaite pourtant suivre le
gouvernement taliban qui se veut plus
flexible et plus ouvert qu'il ya vingt
ans
la communauté internationale a la
responsabilité d'aider les afghans et de
coopérer avec nous de nous reconnaître
par les voies diplomatiques et les
problèmes qu'ils ressentent ou qui l'on
devrait être partagé avec nous par les
voies diplomatiques afin que nous
puissions les résoudre
des efforts jugés insuffisants par la
communauté internationale samedi 18
septembre
seuls les collégiens et lycéens
masculins ont pu reprendre le chemin de
l'école une situation qui alimente
l'inquiétude d'un retour au
fondamentalisme pratiqué par les
talibans durant leur prise de pouvoir
entre 1996 et 2001 leur porte parole se
veut cependant rassurant les filles à
leur tour doivent prendre bientôt le
chemin de l'école
nous essayons grâce à une nouvelle
procédure appropriée de créer un
environnement éducatif sur pour les
femmes et les filles nous y travaillons
j'espère que ce problème sera bientôt
résolu et le ministère de l'éducation
s'y attelle car il s'agit d'un problème
important il concerne les étudiants il
doit donc être résolu dès que possible
nous ne pouvons pas donner de date mais
ce problème sera bientôt résolu on
n'aime pas les paroles
[Musique]
toujours sur ses gardes vis-à-vis du
nouveau gouvernement l'onu a débloqué 45
millions de dollars dettes d'urgence
pour soutenir le système de santé au
bord du gouffre en afghanistan une aide
qui sera répartie en dernier lieu par
des ong nationales et internationales
et le retrait américain en afghanistan
arrivée de tristes souvenirs chez
certaines familles endeuillées nous
sommes allés à la rencontre début
septembre de jean-françois buil en
charente maritime qui a du mal à cacher
sa colère son fils engagé dans l'armée
française est mort il y a raison dans
une embuscade avec les talibans et neuf
autres camarades pour lui paris n'aurait
jamais dû intervenir dans ce pays et son
fils est donc mort pour rien reportage
signé et self âge je suis à
saint-aigulin en charente-maritime je
vais rencontrer jean françois ahuili à
13 ans cet homme père son fils damien le
sergent damian d'huile étaient engagés
dans l'armée française en afghanistan il
est tombé dans une embuscade des
talibans dans la vallée d'uzbin bonjour
monsieur d'huile merci beaucoup de
répondre à nos questions alors vous vous
présentez comme un homme en colère
pourquoi tout simplement parce que
ce que je vois à la télévision
aujourd'hui samsa me supportent je vois
les talibans qui rentre à kaboul en
toute tranquillité pourquoi ça vous met
à spécifiquement colère parce que nos
soldats sont morts pour rien mon fils
est mort pour rien alors le mot rien on
l'a on me le reproche pendant dix ans
c'est pas possible s'ils sont morts pour
rien la preuve c'est un échec total on
est assez négligent en charente maritime
ce lieu je crois qu'il est spécial pour
vous pourquoi ici on est près du
monument aux morts en 2009 le hervé
morin qui était à ce moment là le
ministre des armées avec dominique
bussereau qui était à ce moment là
ministre des transports sont venus
déposer cette cette plaque en l'honneur
de mon fils mort le 18 août 2008 us
green avec neuf de ses camarades donc
c'est un lieu pour moi qui mets qui
représente tout court en fait on est à
13 ans après le décès de votre fils
qu'est ce que vous sentez aujourd'hui en
revenant ici à chaque fois j'ai de
l'émotion alors si vous voulez j'ai pu
j'ai toujours je suis toujours triste
parce que toute façon le bon on a
toujours ça dans la tête à chaque fois
puis aujourd'hui avec tout ce qui se
passe ce qu'on voit à la télé à chaque
fois où ça va et ça revient mon conjoint
hélicoptère passe et bombay j'ai la
gorge serrée quoi ça me je suis je suis
mais l'avait ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
je suis je suis désespéré je suis
écoeuré je suis voilà je suis matraque
et donc on est à le dise 2008 donc c'est
donc la date où votre fils est décédé
comment est ce que vous apprenez la
nouvelle mais on apprend la nouvelle le
matin un coup de téléphone le téléphone
se met à sonner c'est mon épouse qui
répond et c'est les pousses de son
meilleur copain qui était en afghanistan
qui était soldat également qui lui
apprenait que paie notre fils était
décédé avec neuf de ses camarades
voilà c'est tout on n'a pas eu la visite
de gendarmes n'ont même rien du tout
même le régime en rien du tout mais
j'estime que quand même
les gendarmes c'est leur rôle et surtout
le maire de la commune c'est son rôle
mais même pas un coup de téléphone rien
donc là
quand même petit malaise il y avait
quelques fils il avait 31 ans il est
décédé le jour de ses 31 ans puisqu'il
est né le 18 août 2000
1977 et donc 31 ans après le même jour
il décédé je suis au chant regardez là
là il est
là il est en afghanistan voilà il est
sûre le sur le vab voilà
c'est
notre fils vous avez entamé un combat
judiciaire
pourquoi après après le décès de notre
fils un an après on a
on a trouvé on a pensé en réfléchissant
tout en discutant avec les soldats qui
étaient qui était revenu qui était
intervenu qui avait pas été blessés
d'autres blessés on sait on s'est
rencontrés et ils nous ont un petit peu
raconté ce qui s'était passé parce que
des versions on en a eu des versions de
la mort de notre fils puis de tous ses
copains mais la vraie version c'est la
version de ceux qui étaient sur le
terrain il ya eu plat de 2 de
dysfonction il ya eu plein de choses qui
a manquements un manquement donc
nous ne pouvait pas on n'a pas su porter
ça c'est un combat judiciaire qui est
aujourd'hui terminée est ce que vous
êtes satisfait de ce que vous avez de ce
que vous en avez obtenu le ce combat n'a
pas été vain donc on n'a pas eu bien sûr
le résultat parce que escompté puisque
nous on aurait voulu que les
protagonistes de la faire c'est à dire
ces officiers qui n'ont pas été à la
hauteur de la mission à moi je rejette
je le dis franchement bilan il ya eu
tous sont tous montés en grade ils ont
été mutés tranquillou pépère dans
l'ordre dans leurs bottes et
jean-françois à huile ou est ce qu'on
veut et où est ce que l'on est là on au
cimetière de saint-aigulin là où notre
fils est d'enterrer dans cette petite
chapelle
suite aux évènements du 18 août 2008 en
afghanistan je veille à écrire tombés
pour la liberté dans le monde pourquoi
est-ce-que pourquoi cette formule parce
que nos considère avec sa maman que
notre fils et b il est pas mort pour la
france et il est mort sur les terres
d'afghanistan donc nous considérons nous
nous seuls et ça n'engage que nous
sommes inquiets qu'il est mort pour la
paix dans le monde comment est ce
qu'aujourd'hui vous gérer toutes ces
émotions tous ces sentiments
aubin en légère tout seul vous savez là
j'en parle avec mon épouse lors je
m'énerve tout seul devant la télé et
c'est tout ce qu'on peut faire alors on
en parle aussi avec notre association
des alpes à l'eau de la paire à
l'olivier une association en fait pour
les parents qui ont perdu un enfant
landes un conflit militaire sinon c'est
très compliqué de parler de ces
événements avec une personne lambda est
ce que ne comprend pas vous savez 13 ans
après pour beaucoup
c'est très très loin pour nous c'est
c'était hier voilà alors pour le moment
le gouvernement nommé par les talibans
n'est pas reconnu par la plupart des
dirigeants les exigent avant plusieurs
conditions parmi elles le respect du
droit des femmes et son engagement à
laisser partir des béni ce temps ceux
qui le veulent alors comment se
positionner face aux talibans la
communauté internationale doit elle
lever des fonds et comment contrôler si
l'argent utilisé pour venir en aide à la
population afghane c'est l'objet de
notre décryptage ce soir
[Musique]
et avec nous pour en parler olivier
crown ancien officier en afghanistan
ex-conseiller politique à kaboul bonsoir
olivier chrono merci d'être avec nous
shoukria haïdar sur ce plateau
présidente de l'association un égard
association de soutien aux femmes
d'afghanistan bonsoir à vous madame
merci d'être avec nous olivier crown
tout d'abord une réaction à ce
témoignage est évidemment et mouvements
qu'on vient d'entendre ce pas par
endeuillées qui a perdu son fils engagé
en afghanistan au début du reportage on
l'entend il dit les morts pour rien
sous-entendu aujourd'hui voilà vingt ans
après on est au même point au point zéro
peut-on le comprendre de penser c'est ce
qu'il y a de vraies du vrai dans ce
constat terrible
et bien tout d'abord je tiens je
voudrais souligner
le courage de ce père qui a perdu son
fils et salué également
la mémoire et le sacrifice de ce soldat
qui est tombé au combat
donc moi même un ancien d'afghanistan et
je peux comprendre ces questions que
peuvent se poser ou que se posent les
familles lorsque les lorsque leur leur
fils ou leur fille tombe tombe au combat
la mort
maintenant je tiens à souligner qu'il
n'est pas mort pour rien il n'est pas
mort le sacrifice de nos soldats n'a pas
été en vain nous avons été engagés là
bas dans une mission pour défendre des
intérêts stratégiques
il faut le souligner les talibans
al-qaïda et les talibans ce n'étaient
pas nos amis
s'étaient l'afghanistan à ce moment là
était le foyer du jihadisme du
terrorisme international donc nous
avions je dirais de bonnes raisons
d'intervenir la part à ce moment là
maintenant il est toujours facile de
langage de s'engager dans un conflit il
est beaucoup plus difficile d'en sortir
mais il personne ne peut savoir comment
tout ça allait se terminer personne ne
pouvait le savoir à ce moment là donc
je le répète
les soldats le sacrifice de nos soldats
là-bas n'a certainement pas été en vain
ça ça je tiens le dire en tout cas
aujourd'hui de nombreuses voix l'a pas
critique mais enfin constat vingt ans
après c'est vrai que il y a des
interrogations est ce qu'on est revenu
au point zéro c'est aussi l'objet de ce
décryptage ce soir est évidemment la
question tourne beaucoup autour du droit
des femmes notamment
shoukria haïdar un geste aujourd'hui
envers les femmes puisque les talibans à
l'aise dans leur grande bonté un les
collégiennes et lycéennes revenir en
cour aujourd'hui mais on le sait qu'il y
a beaucoup de restrictions les
concernant il y en a tout d'abord aucune
dans le gouvernement contrairement à
leurs promesses c'est quoi c'est un jeu
de dupes c'est se moquer du monde
va écouter les talibans n'ont pas changé
des stratégies et des politiques n'est
dépensée négliger c'est exactement le
même simplement ils ont mûri et elles
ont appris ils ont de bons conseillers
pour chercher à se faire reconnaître par
la communauté internationale elles
disent des mots
part de bojan avec de belles figures et
de bons manière de s'exprimer
mais que derrière les vrais stratèges il
est vrai en sort le vrai militant et le
crie haut et fort
nous appliquons les charia notre charia
non il n'ya pas de doute des redondances
rétorque où ils ont gagné tout au début
oui elles ont appliqué des choses à
creil diaries ont changé la constitution
pour énorme et non la religion non au
dessus de trop l'instant ce n'est pas un
gouvernement d'afghanistan et il faut
qu'il en soit bien clair là dessus
lors ce sont de mélisse ce sont deux
groupes
qu'ils ont compris le territoire mais
elles sont pas reconnues par la
communauté internationale
l'état reconnu internationalement
aux nations-unies et dans toutes les
instances internationales c'est
république
islamique d'afghanistan que sièges
partout donc aux elfes ont tous des
potes bien vous aimez ça cherche à
changer vraiment eu des paroles très
gentil pour justement avoir la
reconnaissance
c'est la clef de tout c'est la clinique
assure
olivier crohn aujourd'hui on le disait
les talibans demandent effectivement une
tribune à l'onu comme l'a dit madame ils
veulent être reconnus
aujourd'hui on imagine avec monétaire
international les pays de l'onu dans une
situation un petit peu embarrassante
quelle stratégie serait la meilleure à
tenir aujourd'hui
c'est
effectivement c'est une question assez
indélicate j'ai envie de dire je rejoins
ce qui vient d'être dit l'instant c'est
à dire tout d'abord les talibans n'ont
pas vraiment changé par rapport à il ya
20 ans je dirais que là la substance à
cela même ils se sont modernisés avec
des comptes twitter etc mais la
substance grasse la même et le programme
politique reste le même et c'est et
c'est ce qui avait été annoncé de toutes
les manières de leur part c'est à dire
c'est la charia
intégral si je puis dire littérale enfin
bref la version en tout cas qui est
extrêmement radical quoi est donc
maintenant ils sont en train de
l'appliquer ni plus ni moins c'est ce
qu'ils avaient dit c'est ce qu'ils font
donc pas surprise de ce côté là
maintenant bon ils sont au pouvoir qu'on
le veuille ou non ils sont au pouvoir
ils ont pris kaboul
est ce que la communauté internationale
doit les reconnaître c'est effectivement
une délicate question
on peut pas évidemment dire qu'il
n'existe pas parce qu'ils sont là ils
sont physiquement au pouvoir à kaboul
maintenant est ce que nous voulons
traiter avec l'eau c'est une tout autre
question et là tu j'aurais effectivement
un avis beaucoup plus tranché
une chose c'est de ne reconnaître un
pays une autre chose c'est de vouloir
traiter avec donc
la problématique est là si vous voulez
est ce que le fait qu'il ya un pouvoir à
kaboul c'est une chose le fait qu'
est-ce que de savoir si vous nous
voulons commencer à le soutenir par
parra par des fonds
que ce soit humanité en pas ou traités
avec ce pays sa ligne tout autre et là
dessus je pense que nous devrions avoir
une très grande réserve effectivement
nous les avons combattu pendant 20 ans
nous avons tout fait pour construire une
alternative à ça bon après 20 ans est un
échec du que c'est l'ennemi qui prend
kaboul ça nous oblige en rien à de voir
les soutenir une quelconque manière en
tout cas certains ont choisi de négocier
avec eux bien avant le retrait américain
se sont tout simplement les les
américains eux-mêmes donald trump
lui-même qui avait commencé les
négociations aujourd'hui on le répète un
gouvernement exclusivement fedom
contrairement aux promesses cette
constitution qu'on le veuille ou non qui
a été modifiée qui les laisse la part
belle à la charia clairement les
américains pour vous madame à ce qu'ils
se sont fait berner ont cette affaire
écoutez pour ma part et pour majorité
toutes les peaux plus d'appréhension les
amérindiens entre guillemets le première
démocratie du monde et sa petite devant
un groupe terroriste pour les intérêts
purement économiques
c'est pas qu'il s'aplatissent ils ont
perdu
oui mais enfin est-ce qu'ils ont eu le
choix cette saison le choix je tremble
ne pensait que cette affaire et ne
faisait que d'affaires
alors maintenant vous en tant que femme
et moi en tant que femme et monsieur en
tant qu'un soldat quelqu'un qui est
quelqu'un qui est combattue quiquet qui
défendez les valeurs
mais je trouve nous a pas demandé qu'est
ce que nous pensons mais la population
d'afghanistan le gouvernement
né des alliés et les traiter tout seul
avec les talibans est le fait de traiter
viletta et maintenant les talibans
veulent l'application des traités que
personne n'était concernée maintenant
tout d'abord mois et la totale est de
proposer des vins ne reconnaît pas cette
traiter cette course et ne pas être
atteints nous ne reconnaît pas nous ne
connaissons pas s'emparer d'une part
ensuite
j'ai dit oh l'effort est clairement et
ça s'est passé pendant ma voix shoukria
haïdar c'est la voix de la majorité de
la profession de l'afghanistan et de
jouer mais la majorité des femmes et des
hommes qui se rencontrent en france
nous avons des valeurs à défendre qui
vient des millénaires
de respect et de démocratie de respect
de la femme
avancer dans leur médication et
verglacée humaine est maintenant un
groupe terroriste qui est monsieur
trempe a fait un accord
et qu'elle saoudien le soutien et que
finances et qatari fait le ranger votre
paquet 120 avant ma mise sur
l'afghanistan dont aux
sept groupes terroristes est sûre
triomphal elles disent haut et fort nous
avons combattu nous avons chassé le plus
grand
force militaire de la planète amérique
avec ses alliés qui sont autant c'est à
dire aimer en course la totalité se le
dise clairement c'est mes crayons ses
disciples c'était culture de débauche
vraiment nous avons là la devoir devoir
je répète nous avons le devoir de
défendre
nos valeurs qui sont juste bons et n'est
pas celle des bancs bride de talibans
olivier comme vous qui avez connu
terrain évidemment qu'on vous entende et
madame et voilà son témoignage émouvant
effectivement
beaucoup partagent ce diagnostic mais
enfin
voilà est-ce qu'il est aujourd'hui mais
le heureusement utopique et c'est un
combat qui est désormais perdu non
salée pendant un temps nous avons
combattu nous avons essayé de comment
dire de nous nous avons défendu ces
valeurs que vient de décrire madame qui
sont des valeurs tous ont également
apprécié intégré par un grand nombre
d'afghans ça c'est une réalité je pense
qu'au bout de vingt ans c'est ce que
nous avons fait pendant 20 ans par par
tous les moyens pas seulement militaire
si lille également économique dans tous
les domaines je pense que le le deal
entre guillemets que
d'en parler madame entre le président
trucks et les talibans en ct ça a été en
quelque sorte ça a été fait c'est une
réalité un petit peu derrière le dos du
prat quand derrière en quelque sorte le
dos des afghans ça c'est une réalité les
américains n'ont pas demandé l'avis
d'ailleurs dans ces négociations là
le gouvernement d'ashraf ghani n'ai pas
fait partie n'était pas impliqué dans
ces discussions il était tenu à l'écart
c'est est ce que voulait d'ailleurs des
talibans ils voulaient négocier
uniquement avec les américains
maintenant vont les américains ou en
tout cas la président l'administration
entre up
au bout de 20 ans dont ils ont jeté
l'épongé ils ont jeté l'épongé parce que
c'était un conflit qu'il y aurait pu
tellement d'années que
les résultats n'étaient pas ceux qui
avaient été fixés entre entre guillemets
quoi donc
maintenant est ce que ça veut dire qu'il
faut arrêter le combat enfin il est
difficile d'imaginer qu'on va retourner
là bas c'est sa part est totalement
illusoire et je pense pas qu'il en est
question maintenant soutenir les valeurs
que nous avons défendues oui et soutenir
effectivement
pas par par d'autres moyens que purement
militaire je dirais un
soutenir les les franges parmi la
population afghane et les forces qui me
titille qui était de notre côté que nous
avons soutenues pendant toutes ces
années de conflit évidemment évidemment
ça je j'ai envie de dire
mais les gens ces gens là qui ont le
courage de continuer le combat là bas
bien évidemment on ne peut pas se
désolidariser 2
vous parliez tout à l'heure également de
l'aide qu'on leur donne de l'aide
effectivement il ya une semaine les
talibans ont remercié d'ailleurs la
communauté internationale qui a permis
quand même de réunir un milliard d'euros
des deux pays la france d'ailleurs à
donner à elle seule 100 millions d'euros
le double des états unis on le voit
apparaître d'ailleurs sur cet écran vous
quel est votre sentiment parce qu'on
sait que la population en a cruellement
besoin un tiers des populations au seuil
de la pauvreté on ne mange pas à sa faim
mais est ce que dans le même temps il ya
un risque que cet argent soit détournée
par les talibans est pas du tout utilisé
pour la population vous le craignez ça
c'est sûr oui mais je pense qu'il ya des
suffisamment des instances
internationales et de des associations à
haut niveau d
agir au niveau mondial comme médecin
demande sont
autant d'autres elle vox d'argent soit
arrivé au niveau de vos pulsions parce
que les pauvres dont ils ont besoin il
faut prier mort de faim et de maladie
ça c'est sûr mais pas que ce soit dans
les mains des talibans
d'une base d'autre part pour répondre à
notre ami je vous permettre de vous
appeler amis
cher monsieur
aujourd'hui les femmes afghanes à
travers de différentes et départements
face à face aux talibans elle raconte
bord droit dans différents départements
les hommes se lève pour défendre
et se mobilisent
comme résistance
s'il est tellement gagner d'un seul coup
tout le département ce n'est pas parce
qu'ils se disent plus fort parce que
l'homme de manière dont elle a fourni à
les autres et les états unis avaient
manigancé et changer sans cesse les
chefs militaires et police et de leur
demander de sortir et rentrer les armes
et les départs toit aux talibans donc
c'est cette manière là qu'ils ont gagné
même les deux départements restaient 5,6
une semaine sans autorité avant que
l'étalement arrêt le récupérer donc
c'est pas qu'ils ont battus qu'ils sont
forts qu'ils sont vraiment gagner donc
on voulait d'une manière le rendre sur
le plateau en oeuvre leur afghanes sont
donc maintenant je ne veux pas entrer
dans ce débat simplement comme sarah
s'il vous plaît sous toujours les
résistances des femmes afghanes selon
les résistants des hommes dans tout
l'intérieur de la guinée sont tous ces
hommes
et cette femme de ce monsieur qui parle
de son enfant qui sont morts pour là
pour porter bonheur 1 ces valeurs qui
sont les nôtres de la relation aux
besoins des régions des pays millénaires
la culture de talibans c'est le panneau
culture de nous ce quelque chose pour
nous il y en a compris en tout cas
valeur message shoukria haïdar merci
d'avoir témoigné
merci également olivier crown d'avoir
été avec nous nous avoir apporté aussi
votre précieux éclairages merci à vous
les directions présent la tunisie où
l'on peine toujours à sortir de la crise
politique le pays est sans gouvernement
depuis presque deux mois après le coup
de force du président kaïs saïd qui
décrète d'ailleurs ce soir plusieurs
dispositions pour réguler l'exercice des
pouvoirs législatif et exécutif et
pouvoirs de la présidence sont
renforcées au détriment du gouvernement
du côté de l'opposition des voix
s'élèvent le parti ennahdha mettant en
garde contre un démantèlement de l'état
des précisions de notre correspondant à
tunis bfm chili
ennahda vent debout contre le président
kaïs ça y est comme de nombreux partis
de l'opposition est la formation
politique conduite par rached ghannouchi
n'a pas tardé à réagir à la locution
surprise du président ça y est une prise
de parole présidentielle qui se voulait
ferme et directives à destination de ses
principaux opposants quand pour leur
rappeler qu'ils comptent bien poursuivre
son opération main propre principale
annonce le maintien des mesures
exceptionnelles entrée en vigueur le 25
juillet dernier et l'adoption d'une
nouvelle loi électorale
il n'en fallait pas plus pour raviver la
colère de l'opposition pour ennahdha le
maintien des mesures exceptionnelles et
l'absence de gouvernement légitime ne
font qu'aggraver la situation politique
et économique du pays et risque
d'entraîner un démantèlement de l'état
je vous propose de les écouter
le président kaïs ça y est depuis sa
décision du 25 juillet dernier continue
d'affirmer qu'il travaill ait agi dans
le cadre de la légitimité et de la
constitution mais ce qui la fait
constitue une grave infraction à la
constitution lors de son dernier
discours à sidi bouzid nous avons
assisté à un changement de ton son
conseiller spécial a confirmé à
plusieurs reprises que le président
s'apprêtait à abolir la constitution
mais face à la réaction des partis et de
la société civile le président s'est
rétracté en annonçant qu'il amenderait
la constitution plutôt que de l'annuler
il a annoncé à sidi bouzid qu'il
adopterait des dispositions transitoires
ce qui constitue un contournement de la
constitution
en d'autres termes il ne souhaite
conserver qu'une partie de la
constitution et abandonné le rêve y
compris les chapitres législatif
exécutif judiciaire et ce qui concerne
la gouvernance locale
nous considérons qu'il s'agit d'une
dérogation à la légitimité et une
abolition de la constitution il est
conscient que le pays est en danger
raison pour laquelle il veut tout
changer cela ne peut se faire sans
dialogue ni participation de tous les
partis politiques nous n'avons pas
hésité à qualifier le coup de force du
25 juillet de coup d'état dès les
premières minutes car le président de la
république s'est retourné contre le
premier ministre en le limogeant sans
réponse constitutionnel puis il a gelé
le président du parlement et toute
l'institution législative et violé
gravement la constitution
ceci bien sûr a été fait par la force il
ne s'agit pas d'un coup d'état militaire
classique le président s'est toujours
retourner contre les institutions grâce
au pouvoir que lui octroie la
constitution en tant que commandant en
chef des forces armées malgré les
inquiétudes de la population et les
attaques de l'opposition le président
saleh semble déterminée à poursuivre son
coup de force nouvelle loi électorale
modification de la constitution encore
élections législatives anticipées
l'agenda de l'homme fort de la tunisie
demeure flou au grand dam des magistrats
avocats société civile partis
d'opposition et qui craignent une dérive
autoritaire cahill sayed qui a déclaré
lundi qu'un nouveau chef du gouvernement
serait bientôt annoncer continue
néanmoins de jouir du soutien d'une
large partie de la population
dans le reste de l'actualité en france
le procès des attentats du 13 novembre
qui se poursuit à la barre aujourd'hui
notamment un commissaire de la bac est
le chef adjointe cette unité de police
de nuit qui était entré au bataclan
compagnie de son chauffeur un véritable
héros qui a permis d'interrompre le
massacre en cours le soir du 13 novembre
quinze ans neutralisant l'un des
kamikazes on retrouve notre reporter
katia technique au palais de justice de
paris bonsoir katia alors c'est la toute
première fois que l'homme apparaît en
public pour prendre donc la parole
racontez nous
oui absolument alors que vous disais
c'était la première fois mais évidemment
sous couvert d'anonymat bien sûr alors
les membres des forces de police
aujourd'hui ont détaillé les assauts qui
ont été menées l'intervention pour
anéantir l'action terroriste ce 13
novembre 2015 et donc pour commencer ce
témoignage inédit d'actes de bravoure
celui du commissaire qui était à
l'époque le numéro deux de la bac de
nuit et c'est lui qui est entré en
premier dans le bataclan avec son
chauffeur seulement 12 minutes rendez
vous compte après le début des
fusillades et d'ailleurs les terroristes
étaient encore en train de mitrailler
ils n'étaient que deux quasiment sans
protection ils ont réussi à tirer et
touche est évidemment un des trois
terroristes ami-ami moore qui s'est
écroulé au sol et qui a ensuite activé
sa ceinture d'explosifs
mais il était évidemment insuffisamment
équipées donc ils ont dû attendre
l'arrivée des équipes de la berri ils
ont donc profité bien sûr pour extraire
quelques victimes ce qui est un geste
évidemment salutaire ils ont
certainement sauvé la vie de nombreuses
personnes et ensuite christophe molmy
qui a dirigé la berri à l'époque a
poursuivi les explications alors à ce
stade en fait les équipes de la berri
arrive à 22h20 et ils sécurisent ils
évacuent les blessés et qu'ils les
évacuent le plus de monde possible et
ensuite à 23h une forme de colonne pour
libérer les balcons car les terroristes
qui reste deux se sont retranchés avec
des otages à 23h15 des premières
négociations s'engagent mais elles n'ont
pas de résultats alors le feu vert est
donné pour un assaut qui débute à 00h18
la colonne en caisse avec des boucliers
à spécialiser le feu nourris de
kalachnikov des deux terroristes ils
sont repliés au fond du couloir vers un
escalier le premier se fait exploser
heureusement il n'y a pas de
conséquences graves sur les hommes qui
sont à sa poursuite et le second veut a
priori aussi se faire exploser mais il
est abattu par les forces de police et
puis ils libèrent au fur et à mesure les
personnes qui sont cachés et les otages
00h25 c'est la fin de l'assaut il n'y a
pas eu d'otage qui a été tué dans cet
assaut il n'y a juste eu un opérateur
blessés ce qui est un véritable miracle
merci katia technique qui suit donc pour
nous le procès historique du 13 novembre
qui se tient en ce moment au palais de
justice de paris merci m
la france sont bruno le maire a présenté
le dernier budget du quinquennat à
maquereau ans lors du conseil des
ministres ce matin mais des finances qui
a dû défendre son projet face aux
critiques de l'opposition mais également
par le haut conseil des finances
publiques robin pu l
le gouvernement pris et de préciser son
budget
le haut conseil des finances publiques a
critiqué le dernier projet budgétaire du
quinquennat d'emmanuel matheron présenté
ce mercredi en conseil des ministres par
bruno le maire c'est la première fois
depuis 2016 que l'instance indépendante
rend un avis aussi sévère avec un projet
de loi de finances
le haut conseil déplore notamment un
manque d'information le projet de loi de
finances pour 2022 dans le haut conseil
a été saisi est incomplet en effet une
intègre pas l'impact de mesures
d'ampleur qui ont pourtant déjà été
annoncé par le gouvernement le haut
conseil regrette ces conditions de
saisine qui ne lui permettent pas de
rendre un avis pleinement éclairer sur
les prévisions de finances publiques
pour 2022 à l'intention du parlement et
des citoyens en application de son
mandat un tlf 2022 également fustigé
dans les rangs de l'opposition qui
déplore en quoi qu'il en coûte
électorale les représentants de tous
bords politiques estiment que les
promesses budgétaires servirait la
compagne d'emmanuelle macron à sept mois
de l'élection présidentielle
face à ces attaques
bruno lemaire défend son projet je veux
le dire aux français nous avons dépensé
l'argent public à bon escient pour vous
protégez pour protéger l'emploi pour
protéger des compétences pour protéger
des entreprises le quoi qu'il en coûte
décidée par le président de la
république a été une politique réfléchie
une politique efficace et une politique
nécessaire alors que les oppositions qui
critiquent nos dépenses nous disent
lesquels elle voudrait supprimer
ce qu'elles veulent revenir sur
l'augmentation du budget de la défense
est ce qu'elles veulent revenir sur
l'augmentation des moyens 10 aux données
aux policiers c'est à dire à ceux qui
nous protège est ce qu'elles veulent
revenir sur le chèque énergie qui permet
d'apporter 100 euros de plus à ceux qui
ont le plus de difficultés à se chauffer
emmanuel macron doit prendre la parole
dans les jours à venir afin de préciser
les grandes lignes du plan
d'investissement voulu par le
gouvernement
le projet budgétaire sera ensuite
discuté à l'assemblée nationale à partir
du 11 octobre
et pour en parler nous sommes sur ce
plateau en direct avec henri sterdyniak
économiste et membre des économistes
atterrés bonsoir henri sterdyniak soir
beaucoup d'être avec nous budget 2022
présentait donc aujourd'hui pointé du
doigt largement par l'opposition qui
estime trop dispense yeux c'est une
critique justifiée pour l'économiste que
vous êtes
d'abord il faut savoir que nous sortons
d'une grande dépression et donc le
gouvernement a choisi de ne pas
pratiquer de politiques d'austérité à
oreste avec un déficit de 4,8 pour cent
du pipe ce qui est quand même très
important
en sens inverse il faut dire que il ya
eu des dépenses et des baisses d'impôts
qui sont pas financés et donc le 4 8 %
du déficit il faudra
le risque c'est que il va il va falloir
le combler en 2023 2024 et donc disons
ça c'est un budget de transition qui
garantit que on est une année 2022
relativement satisfaisante là on est
dans le court terme 2022 vous l'avez dit
sauf que la dette qui déjà abyssal se
creuse encore davantage
ça ne vous inquiète pas plus que ça
ça doit pas trop de inquiétez d'abord
parce qu'on sent d'être toujours à des
taux extrêmement faible on s'endette à à
0% donc la situation n'est pas
dramatique à le problème lorsqu'il faut
avoir conscience et que le gouvernement
a dépensé beaucoup d'argent en 2020 2021
les ménages n'ont pas consommé durant
ces années 20 les plus aisés il aura
cumulé
des ave d2 les parcs cette épargne elle
finance le déficit public et donc ya pas
de raison de s'inquiéter a priori à la
france peut toujours financer son
déficit et si par hasard les plus aisés
ceux des ports se décider à dépenser ce
serait quand même
favorable à l'activité alors
effectivement le gouvernement se défend
lui un il dit qu'il a fait le choix d'un
budget de relance et d'investissement
pour pour 2022 est ce que c'est vraiment
le cas parce que la question qu'on
attend sur les lèvres c'est qui va payer
et tout le monde craint évidemment une
chose peut-être de la pression fiscale
déjà très élevé en france tibor il faut
voir que le gouvernement
le volant ou ne voulons pas change
complètement son fusil d'épaulé par
rapport à ce qu'avait été le programme
électoral de 2009 27 on a une hausse de
la part des dépenses publiques dans le
pib et comme bien de dire bruno le maire
toutes ces dépenses sont nécessaires par
contre le gouvernement à baisser de
façon importante les impôts 50 milliards
depuis
2002 depuis son arrivée au pouvoir et du
coup on a un déficit important qui qui
demeure et qui va peser après 2000 après
2022 c'est la grande si on peut dire
c'est la grande inconnue que vas tu que
va-t-on faire en 2023 demi 27 vous
l'avez dit des hausses de budget un je
vais pas tous les citer mais enfin la
défense le ministère de l'intérieur
notamment un besoin sécuritaire à la
proche de l'élection présidentielle dont
on sait que ça va être l'un des grands
enjeux
emmanuel macron n'est d'ailleurs pas le
seul à l'avoir fait
voilà cette dépense à tout va à quelques
mois de la présidentielle
monsieur françois hollande l'avait fait
aussi nicolas sarkozy avant lui oui
disons qu on a des secteurs où il ya des
besoins plus ou moins criant la justice
là
la défense la police et d'autres l'art
on a une année où effectivement les
bercy a dû céder aux ministères
dépensiers 1 sans doute il manque on n'a
pas sans doute fait assez pour
l'éducation et pour la santé on verra la
semaine prochaine le plan de financement
de la sécurité sociale qui également
été extrêmement importante par les
marques ce qui met en jeu jusqu'à
présent on peut dire c'est un budget
dans lequel on dépense de façon
importante pour satisfaire des besoins
contrairement à au programme de macron
dans lequel on disait il est possible de
réduire fortement les dépenses publiques
là par exemple faut prendre un autre
exemple le nombre de fonctionnaires ne
va pas baisser alors que dans le
programme de maquereaux ils devaient
baisser extrêmement fortement
merci en tout cas on y sert direct de
nous avoir apporté votre éclairage ce
soit resté avec nous dans quelques
instants nous parlons de la situation
sanitaire en france fin du port du
masque à l'école primaire le 4 octobre
prochain dans les territoires les moins
touchés par le cos vide
[Musique]
à
la veille à d'un procès historique le
procès des attentats du 13 novembre 2015
comment vous l'avez abordé je crois que
les victimes attendent de pouvoir
témoigner une exigence de vérité une
exigence de justice nous allons les
accompagner du début de la crise jusqu'à
leur reconstruction dante est que ce
soit possible pour certaines on parle
beaucoup de l'accompagnement
psychologique mais il ya tout un champ
d'accompagnement autres et
l'indemnisation qui est extrêmement
importante pour ces personnes la
problématique va être quel prix va-t-on
assigné à la douleur quel prix vaut
votre fille quel prix votre père et
c'est impossible c'est un procès pour
les victimes c'est un procès également
pour la république il ne s'agit de rien
d'autre que de juger des hommes qui ont
commis un attentat sur le territoire qui
doivent être condamnés
le résultat d'un dieu peut réserver bien
des surprises pour mieux comprendre où
vous aideront à y voir clair
[Musique]
si paris cette saison avec lionel messi
remporte la ligue des champions août du
symbolisme en termes de technique ce
sera absolument parfait et ils veulent
une fanfare est impossible pour la coupe
du monde 2022 qui est la priorité de
l'émirat pourquoi le qatar utilise le
sport le foot plus particulièrement
comme outil de ce soft power ici vous
regarde en termes d'argent le faut ce
qu'on dit c'est de l'argent si c'est que
dalle en fait ces pilotes donc si vous
voulez aujourd'hui être affiché à
travers tous les continents avoir une
image et en plus un an de la coupe du
monde et ses rêvés pour le qatar parce
qu'on va reparler d'eux et encore pour
des raisons on va dire plutôt mélioratif
plus tôt m
[Musique]
il est 21h merci nous rejoindre en
direct sur rt france le passé ni ter
maintenus pour l'instant dans tous les
départements français en revanche fin du
port du masque à l'école primaire le 4
octobre prochain dans les territoires
les moins touchés par le coït 19 pour
certains syndicats du primaire la levée
partielle de cette obligation semble
précipité alors faut-il s'inquiéter de
cette direction prise par le
gouvernement après ces annonces quelles
pistes pourraient être proposées par
l'exécutif on tente tout à l'heure de
répondre à ces questions
dès le 4 octobre terminé donc le port du
masque à l'école primaire pour les
départements peu touché par le cos vie
19 en revanche le pass sanitaire est
maintenu partout en france pour le
moment des déclarations du porte parole
du gouvernement cet après midi à l'issue
d'un conseil de défense qui s'est tenue
ce matin les détails avec pierre pissavy
yvernault
l'allègement des restrictions sanitaires
voilà le sujet dont on parle et les
membres du conseil de défense mercredi
dans une conférence de presse qui en
détaille le contenu le porte parole du
gouvernement gabriela talent indique que
la décrue de l'épidémie se confirme de
jour en jour une donnée qui permet au
gouvernement de desserrer l'étau dans
les écoles primaires du pays dès le 4
octobre prochain à partir du lundi 4
octobre dans les départements où le taux
d'incidence se stabilise au dessous du
seuil de 50 pour cent mille habitants le
protocole scolaire passera en niveau 1
ce qui signifie essentiellement que
l'obligation du port du masque à l'école
primaire il sera levé dès réponses
autour du pass and i ter était aussi
particulièrement attendu si de nombreux
français dénoncent chaque samedi sa mise
en application
gabriella talent s'est voulue sur ce
point plutôt clair le pass sanitaires
restent en vigueur sur l'ensemble du
territoire d'abord on l'a toujours dit
on a toujours été très clair sur ce
sujet mais c'est toujours bien de le
redire on n'est pas fétichiste du pass
sanitaires si on pouvait se passer du
pass sanitaires on s'en passerait grâce
à l'avancé 2 la vaccination est grâce au
pass sanitaires nous avons vu la vie
reprendre dans l'ensemble de ces lieux
et nous n'avons pas eu à refermer ces
lieux alors même que nous avions des
taux d'incidence très élevé et nous le
devons notamment au pass sanitaires et
dans le cas où il y aurait une nécessité
de devoir prendre des mesures on sera
content d'avoir la possibilité
d'utiliser le passé annie terre plutôt
qu'avoir à refermer des lieux dans les
france dont les français profitent et
des lieux dans lesquels dont les
français ont envie de pouvoir continuer
évidemment a profité ce sont des lieux
de vie et de lien social autre annonce
confirmée par le porte parole du
gouvernement les 12 17 ans devront
bientôt présenter un passani terre dans
certaines situations à compter du 30
septembre impasse sanitaire qui ne
risque donc pas de disparaître dans les
prochaines semaines selon l'entourage du
premier ministre un projet de loi serait
même en préparation pour le projet il
devrait être présenté le 13 octobre
prochain en conseil des ministres
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
alexis poulain bonsoir alexis alors
roulement de tambour aujourd'hui à
l'occasion du dernier conseil de défense
aujourd'hui on se disait qu'est ce qui
va sortir du chapeau et bien le pack
sanitaire finalement et bien ça continue
ça continue mais ça continue
stéphanie je n'arrive pas à comprendre
en fait je crois que beaucoup de
français sont perdus alors on nous parle
d'allègement et en même temps le fameux
en même temps le gouvernement se donne
quand même l'opportunité de pouvoir
prolonger ce pass sanitaire alors que
tous les chiffres vont bien qu'on a 50
millions de français vaccinés que les
courbes vont dans le bon sens alors
c'est vraiment j'ai découvert par
exemple jeunes qui avaient encore des
jauges je pensais qu'il y avait plus de
jauger bas il y en a encore et puis
alors après ça dépend des régions et
puis on a ce fameux taux d'incidence le
nombre de malades par cent mille
habitants alors quand on nous avait des
confiné il ya quelques mois de ça
c'était 400 le taux d'incidence un bon
400 nouveaux cas pour 100000 habitants
là on est à 50 nouveaux cas pour 100000
habitants pour pouvoir dire que ça va
mieux dans certains départements et
c'est plus d'une centaine de
départements où ça va bien et on voit
bien que le gouvernement fait de la
politique du doigt mouillé il est en
train d'essayer de gérer de voir que la
rentrée se passe mieux que prévu il n'y
a pas de rebond épidémique en réalité et
donc il faut comprendre aussi voir la
colère de tous ces manifestants anti
passe tous les week-ends et faire
comprendre bien une mesure qui n'a plus
vraiment de raison d'être si ça va mieux
alors il faut dire qu'on doit rester
prudent vigilant et garder ces mesures
mais il ya des mesures qu'on ne comprend
plus c'était depuis le début quand même
depuis mars 2020 entre les autos
attestation de sortie le couvre-feu à
19h à 21h à 20 heures on sait plus du
tout ce qu'ils étaient ouverts ce qui
était ferme et maintenant on nous dit
que le pass nous permet d'ouvrir des
choses et en même temps on voit bien que
le rebond économique n'est pas encore
vraiment au rendez vous donc on se sent
bien qu'il ya encore des freins pour que
la vie reprenne on est loin évidemment
donc c'est vraiment dû en même temps
typiquement ma chronique pour à la fois
faire de l'argent qu'ils sont
contradictoires et donner un peu à boire
et à manger entre le coup de bâton et la
carotte alors en revanche à en tomber le
masque tout de même un petit progrès aux
primaires il faut être jeune vince et on
en est loin malheureusement désolé adexi
or nous voilà dans les départements les
plus touchés en tout cas alors certains
syndicats là pour le coup grogne y
compris certains médecins qui
s'interroge sur la pertinence d'une
telle décision on voit les médecins
depuis le début de cette crise qui ne
sont pas d'accord il ya plusieurs écoles
entre les alarmistes les rassure east
ceux qui disent qu'on pourrait faire
autre chose et la question des enfants
elle est centrale est-ce qu'on attrape
le comider à l'école est ce qu'on le
donne à l'école est ce qu'après on le
ramène à la maison le ministère de
l'éducation ne publie pas les chiffres
il ya une opacité totale sur les
chiffres de l'éducation nationale et les
4 go vite donc il ya peut-être quelque
chose qui se passe là mais on voit que
les rebonds épidémiques ont lieu plus
tôt pendant les vacances donc pas
vraiment quand l'école reprend mais
plutôt quand on est dans le cercle
familial et quand on est dans les pièces
fermées donc là encore on navigue à vue
et je crois que il ya par contre
beaucoup de médecins qui sont en train
de voir les ravages cognitif que font
les masses notamment pour les enfants
les plus jeunes qui ont du mal dans
l'apprentissage de la lecture de
l'écriture et de pleins et plein et
plein de 2,2 besoins fondamentaux de
l'éducation nationale donc évidemment le
masque est un frein pour ses enfants et
il faut voir aussi on parle toujours de
bénéfices risques est bien là clairement
des enfants qui risquent beaucoup moins
que d'autres populations d'attraper ce
virus est d'avoir des formes graves
pourquoi leur imposer un masque alors
que pour eux ça devient maintenant un
vrai boulet notamment pour
l'apprentissage des fondamentaux a en
revanche au-dessus de 12 ans est une
forme de vaccination obligatoire qui dit
pas son nom on rappelle que les enfants
qui font des activités ne peuvent plus y
accéder à partir du 30 septembre les
parents les emmène pas se faire vacciner
exactement là on pousse à la vaccination
quasiment vaccination obligatoire dès 12
ans en france sauf qu'on n'utilise pas
ces mots là c'est ce fameux pas
sanitaire qui oblige cents contre un
apparent en contraignant mais sans
obliger donc on est dans un entre deux
dans un flou juridique également 1,2
mais comme depuis le début avec ses
conseils de défense ou haendel macron
décide seul entouré de quelques-uns pour
dire aux français ce qu'ils doivent
faire et d'une semaine à l'autre ça
change et donc qu'est ce qui va se
passer si vous vacciner des enfants de
12 ans et que dans un mois il ya plus de
passes annie terre pourquoi faire une
chose pareille est-ce que c'est
nécessaire la question qui se pose et
certains pays l'ont fait a notamment
israël ils ont testé massivement les
enfants pour savoir s'il avait ou non le
coc vide parce que a ces moments on est
jeune et on a déjà une copine il n'y a
pas forcément besoin de vaccination est
certainement pas de deux doses en france
rien de tout ça c'est à dire que la
politique sanitaire elle est vraiment
faite à la hache en disant on va essayer
d'avoir un nombre de vaccinés pour dire
que on est les meilleurs en europe et
peu importe si ça a un sens ou pas sur
le plan sanitaire alors en tout cas
l'excès on sent qu emmanuel macron et
est un peu impatient tout de même comme
l'ont d'ailleurs de clore ce chapitre au
vide mais qui serait pour lui et pas
pour nous un un boulet pour la
présidentielle alors tout le monde en a
ras le bol du coc vide ça fait deux ans
qu'on vit avec ce truc on a l'impression
que c'est la saison de trop et tout le
monde dans l'impression et
particulièrement les politiques qui
veulent dire qu'ils ont été les
vainqueurs du virus emmanuel macron a
tout fait tout et n'importe quoi dans
cette gestion de crise il l'a dit tout
et son contraire le passé ni terre qui
rappelez vous nous devez pas être là
pour régir les activités du quotidien et
peint paf voilà un passé iter pour aller
boire un café en terrasse le mas qui
servait à rien et c'est donc aujourd'hui
elle macron s'il a une chose à faire
avant d'entrer officiellement en
campagne même si c'est très tard mais il
est déjà en campagne sans le dire c'est
de mettre le coc vide derrière lui et de
dire oui il y a eu plus de cent dix
mille morts 116000 morts en france nous
devons nous de se rappeler 2d des
défaillances qui a pu avoir il ne fait
jamais son mea culpa sur cette base là
mais au moins s'il veut un bilan pas
soko vide ils doivent fermer la porte du
coc vide avant que la campagne vraiment
de commence merci alexis paulin d'avoir
été avec nous et le gouvernement
français inquiet mise sur la campagne de
vaccination mais peine à convaincre
certains parents réticents on a parlé
une vaccination qui a du coup dû mal à
décoller dans le cadre scolaire la
tranche d'âge des 12-17 ans affiche un
taux de 70% de primo vacciner 58% reçu
alors de doses pour l'ensemble des
français on a franchi la semaine
dernière la barre des 50 millions de
primo vacciner s'il s'agit d'une étape
importante pour l'exécutif certains
territoires accusent d'importants
retards comme le département de
seine-saint-denis
l'éclairage de david khalifa
fierté affichée par l'exécutif mais
réalité beaucoup moins flatteuse une
réalité représentatif d'une fracture
sociale qui continue de se creuser avec
le coc u19 ce cap des 50 millions de
primo vacciner révèlent des disparités
entre des territoires sur vacciner et
d'autres sous vacciner certaines villes
du 93 en font partie malgré le 26e drôme
du stade de france où je me trouve
actuelle emmanuel vigneron géographe à
réaliser cette carte en se basant sur
les données de l'assurance maladie
depuis le 25 juillet une carte qui donne
un indice de vaccination des
intercommunalités jusqu'au 5 septembre
dernier on s'aperçoit que le clivage est
bien réel entre le sud est de la france
et le nord une situation qui n'a pas
évolué depuis l'annnonce du pass
sanitaire dans ces territoires quand on
regarde de plus près la région ile de
france le constat est le même pour la
seine saint denis les quartiers
défavorisés accuse les retards les plus
importants dans ces zones situées à
quelques kilomètres de la capitale près
de 50% de la population n'a pas reçu la
moindre dose de vaccin
globalement les premiers sont toujours
les premiers et les derniers toujours
les derniers c'est le signe d'une
dimension territoriale forte de la
résistance à la vaccination cela peut
être aussi celui de trous dans la
raquette du dispositif vaccinale les
deux pouvant se cumuler si le professeur
évoque un trou dans la raquette c'est
que l'intégralité des populations non
encore vaccinés ne peut être mise sur le
compte d'un rejet des vaccins pour
rappel le ministère de la santé estime
que 8 millions cinq cent mille personnes
restent à convaincre en france
s'agissant de la vaccination mais pour
la plupart des gens qui habitent elle
dans ces quartiers défavorisés il ne
s'agit pas d'une résistance ou d'un
refus mais plutôt d'un manque
d'accompagnement jugez plutôt par
vous-même parmi les 50 territoires les
moins vacciner du pays 10% sont situés
en seine saint denis clichy sous bois
villetaneuse teint ou bien encore
villepinte les raisons de ce décalage
sont nombreuses et parfois assez
surprenante selon elle les
infrastructures en charge de combler ce
retard au sein des populations éloignées
à des soins les réticences sont bien
souvent liée à la barrière de la langue
ou à la crainte d'une expulsion pour
ceux dont les papiers ne sont pas en
règle
tu apprends sans même que le vaccin est
payant dans les quartiers nord de
marseille à la maison de santé des
aygalades où l'on vaccine le week end
l'une des premières choses qu'on précise
bien quand on appelle des habitants
c'est que le vaccin est gratuit
ça peut paraître aberrant mais certains
pensent encore que c'est payant face à
cette crise sanitaire il faut vraiment
adapté une vaccination au plus près des
gens
parce que c'est aussi une question de
confiance c'est aussi des réseaux qui
savent se mettre en mouvement rien ne
remplacera la vaccination au plus près
des gens donc c'est à dire des centres
des vaccins proximité je ne dis pas des
centres de vaccins
communal mais vraiment très proche des
gens y compris nous un instant on peut
on peut aisément aussi vacciner des
personnes qui sont sur les quartiers
nord de saint denis dont une proche de
stains et cetera vous l'aurez compris le
retard de la vaccination dans certains
endroits du pays restent un problème
bien plus profond pour la france celui
des inégalités sanitaires en fonction
les territoires une prise de conscience
qui servira peut-être d'électrochoc à
l'exécutif pour considérer un mal et qui
était présent bien avant la crise
sanitaire et conservant toujours la
campagne de vaccination les etats-unis
comptent doubler leurs dons de ses
romantique hobbit dans le monde leur
objectif vacciner 70 % de la population
de chaque pays d'ici un an washington
qui a déjà exprimé à ce jour 160
millions de doses aux quatre coins de la
planète les etats-unis serviront
d'ailleurs début novembre leurs
frontières aux voyageurs internationaux
vacciner est une bonne nouvelle pour
l'économie notamment les compagnies
aériennes à maillas troubler
une décision qui permet de rouvrir les
portes des états unis aux voyageurs
internationaux
dicté par la science selon le
coordinateur de la lutte contre le coc
vite 19 auprès de la maison blanche
ce lundi jefferies giants a annoncé que
tous les voyageurs entièrement vacciner
pourront à nouveau franchir les
frontières américaines à partir du mois
de novembre
une nouvelle étape vers un retour à la
normale salué outre atlantique les
citoyens européens pleinement vacciner
pourront bientôt de nouveau se rendre
aux états unis nous saluons cette
décision qui permettra aux proches et
aux amis de se retrouver et aux voyages
d'affaires de reprendre je suis ravi qu
à partir de novembre que joe biden
rétablisse les voyages transatlantiques
afin que les ressortissants britanniques
entièrement vacciner puis se rendre aux
états unis c'est un formidable coup de
pouce pour les affaires le commerce et
c'est formidable que la famille et des
amis des deux côtés de l'étang puisse à
nouveau être réunis réunis mais sous
certaines conditions
en plus d'être complètement vaccinés les
touristes et voyageurs d'affaires
devront effectuer un test maximum trois
jours avant leur voyage et porter un
masque les compagnies aériennes mettront
également en place un système de suivi
des contacts afin de prévenir les
passagers concernés
ces contraintes sont loin de dissuader
les candidats au départ
les recherches de vols entre l'europe et
les états unis ont flambé depuis
l'annnonce du pentagone
l'augmentation du trafic sur notre site
skyscanner a augmenté d'environ 50% dans
l'heure qui a suivi l'annoncé mais le
plus important est l'augmentation des
recherches des voyageurs nous avons vu
des personnes du royaume uni vraiment
désireuse de rentrée pour rendre visite
à leur famille ou à leurs amis aux états
unis avec des recherches qui ont
augmenté de plus de 500% juste un jour
après l'annoncé c'est similaire à
travers le pays donc les recherches ont
augmenté de 250% en france de plus de
300% en allemagne et même de plus de
400% en irlande exit donc l'interdiction
de voyager instauré par donald trump
rester en vigueur pendant 18 mois reste
une inconnue la liste des vaccins
reconnu par les états unis
et du côté de la russie à présent les
quatre commis dix neuf repartent à la
hausse à moscou 100 % ces nouveaux cas
dans la capitale sont des contaminations
aux variants delta selon les autorités
locales ont fait le point avec notre
correspondante sur place des ragots of
man
nouveau record de décès en russie 817 me
rende dernières 24 heures à cause du coc
vidant nouveau pic de décès s'ajoute la
hausse des contaminations presque vingt
mille nouveaux cas de coronavirus le
médecin anthony tranchet fameux popover
déploré le manque de confiance de la
population à l'égard des vaccins malgré
leur disponibilité ainsi que le nombre
peu élevé des personnes entièrement
vacciner je vous propose d'écouter
aujourd'hui près de 40 millions de
personnes en russie de personnes adultes
sont complètement vaccinés contre le
coronavirus le nombre de personnes
vaccinées qui ont changé d'attitude à
l'égard des vaccins augmente chaque jour
il faut qu'il y en ait plus c'est triste
quand on a le plus grand nombre de
personnes au centre de vaccination au
moment où c'est le pic de morbidité
quand les gens ont peur alors qu'il est
préférable d'arriver au dic en ayant
déjà l'imminuté c'est certain vous voyez
nous rencontrons tous le vire tout le
monde il sera confronté c'est inévitable
si une personne n'a pas d'immunité alors
on ne sait pas comment cette rencontre
peut se terminer aux institutions aux
gones la situation à moscou se
compliquent également selon la maire
adjointe de moscou anastacia kova cela
est dû à la prépondérance du variante
delta du coronavirus dans la capitale
écoutez
par rapport à la semaine dernière la
hausse est de 24% et les
hospitalisations ont augmenté de 15%
moscou est actuellement dominée à 100%
par le variant delta ii coronavirus
pour le traitement des patients atteints
de corona dire eu ce délit en nombre
suffisant ont été déployés est réservé
dans la ville
moscou a enregistré près de deux mille
nouveaux cas de coronavirus ces
dernières 24 heures une augmentation des
contaminations qui s'explique selon les
autorités par le retour des congés des
moscovites et les rentrées scolaires et
directions l'australie où les
manifestations anti vaccins se
poursuivre dans les cortèges hier à
melbourne des ouvriers du bâtiment il
dénonce une nouvelle fois la fermeture
de chantiers constructions une décision
des autorités pour non respect des
règles que 8,19 marion que dalle avec
mikel dos santos
des manifestants arrêtés par la police
australienne
les scènes se répètent depuis plusieurs
jours dans les rues des opposants à
l'obligation vaccinale pour les ouvriers
du bâtiment lundi le rassemblement a
dégénéré les manifestants décident alors
d'enfoncer la porte des bureaux des
syndicats de travailleurs de la
construction
la police anti-émeute intervient et
tirent des balles en caoutchouc pour
disperser les quelques 500 manifestants
alors qu'il est en plein direct un
journaliste local est prise à partie
je viens d'être frappé à l'arrière de la
tête par une canette cela fait vraiment
mal aujourd'hui on m'a attrapé par le
cou on m'a renversé de lure in dessus et
maintenant on m'a jeté une canette de
boisson énergisante
des comportements inacceptables selon le
chef de la police de victoria
nous avons donné la priorité à l'ordre
public nous avons envoyé nos
spécialistes sur le terrain et les
équipes de maintien de l'ordre public
ont utilisé des ballons de poivre ils
les ont déployé nous avons utilisé des
balles de matraque en mousse nous avons
également utilisé des cartouches
fumigènes en plus de cela des grenades
stinger qui déploient des boulettes de
caoutchouc ces munitions d'équipements
de contrôle de foule étaient nécessaires
et elles le sont toujours car nous ne
pouvons pas permettre que ce type de
comportement continue comme d'actes
garonne en réponse aux troubles et à la
propagation de l'épidémie l'exécutif a
décidé mardi de fermer tous les
chantiers de la région de melbourne et
ce pour les deux prochaines semaines des
violences qui inquiète le gouvernement
aura canada ce thème je peux comprendre
que les gens s'inquiètent de la
fermeture de l'industrie de la
construction ce sont des emprunts
importants et ils reviendront nous
allons nous en sortir mais l'activité de
protestation est ce que nous avons vu là
bas je pense est très pénible et ce
n'est pas une réponse appropriée pour
essayer de faire face une épée des mines
de cette nature
pour rouvrir avant le 5 octobre prochain
les employés devront être vaccinés et
prouver leur respect des consignes
sanitaires
les mobilisations anti vaccins se
multiplient ici et là dans le même temps
amnesty international dénonce la
cupidité des laboratoires qui produisent
ces roms dans un rapport publié
aujourd'hui les ong à cussy groupe
pharmaceutique d'alimenter je cite une
crise des droits humains sans précédent
résumé en images
[Musique]
je
[Applaudissements]
le blocage intentionnelle des transferts
de technologie par big pharma et ses
manoeuvres commercial al'avantage des
pays riches ont créé une pénurie de
vaccins certaines régions d'amérique
latine d'afrique et d'asie doivent faire
face à de nouvelles flambées du virus
[Musique]
sur fond de telles inégalités les
entreprises biotech moderna et phaser
s'apprête à engranger à l 330 milliards
de recettes d'ici à la fin 2022
[Musique]
et c'est la fin de cette émission merci
de l'avoir suivi on se retrouve demain à
20 heures pour un prochain numéro en
attendant l'actualité continue toute la
soirée en direct sur rt france
[Musique]
chacun prétend détenir la vérité trop
souvent il ne s'agit que de spéculations
[Musique]